I'm back I'm back baby as some of you
may have noticed I took a vacation last
week don't do that very often but I did
it last week I flew in last night from
the United Kingdom after an incredibly
busy week in Mary old England toppling
their government that was important
helping to baptize Candace's baby and
hitting every single tourist spot with
my wife and two little children I am a
little bit tired but I promise you I
promise you this right now I am nowhere
near as tired as the President of the
United States
I have not made that formal decision but
it's my intention my intention to run
again and we have time to make that
decision
uh Dr Biden is for it
Mr President oh Dr Biden thinks that uh
my wife thinks that uh
that I
that that were that were doing something
very important
the media have been metaphorically
propping up Biden for years they are now
literally propping him up as he appears
almost to doze off on camera
you are seeing this desperate propping
reflected right now in the polls as the
midterms approach now just over two
weeks away the polls are all breaking
for Republicans now in years past
Republicans could already reasonably
start chilling the champagne for the
victory parties but many conservatives
still feel a nagging worry that no
matter how good we're looking in the
polls somehow the votes on Election Day
or whenever they finish counting the
ballots this year are miraculously going
to just turn at the end and favor the
Democrats a lot of conservatives have
the nagging worry that if the powers
that be can continue so brazenly to prop
up our cadaver in Chief then our entire
electoral system as we know it might be
on the brink of death too I'm Michael
Knowles as the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Michael Michael storeman who says
calling the January 6th committee a
kangaroo court is an insult to kangaroos
absolutely true and and the the kangaroo
court and the constant vilification of
half the country is semi-fascist and
illegitimate and all the rest of it that
is why conservatives in particular don't
have a ton of faith in the electoral
system right now because we're
consistently told that our views are not
legitimate they have no role in our
sacred democracy to save our democracy
you got really got to get rid of half of
the country and then we saw all the
shenanigans in 2020 and so we look we
say yeah we're doing great in the polls
right now
but will that matter on Election Day or
is our
Republic dead
is it dead like all of us will be one
day which is why you need to check out
epic will right now head on over to
epicwill.com use promo code Knowles what
does your family believe in faith church
on Sunday do you believe in serving do
you do you want to vaccinate your kids
give them the fauci ouchy do you want to
say no I don't think so how does your
family Define men and women what kind of
values do they put on a life
your children look to you to Define
their beliefs their perspectives of the
world what if you were not here to do
that for them in the event that you die
and we're all going to die someday folks
who will ensure that the values you hold
dear are upheld by your kids epic will
can help with that a will lets you
determine who will raise your kids in
the event that you die before you're
done raising them this is a big deal
it's your responsibility as a parent to
figure it out that's why we at the daily
wire have partnered with epic will take
five minutes today go to epicwill.com
and use promo code Knowles that will
save you 10 percent on Epic Wheels
complete will package more importantly
it will let me know that you did it okay
talk about accountability that's
accountability to me baby epicwill.com
promo code Knowles the polls are looking
great what a great way to come back into
the United States I look at the poll in
Pennsylvania right now Dr Oz is leading
John Federman by four and a half points
and I have made no bones about my views
on Dr Oz I think he is an extremely weak
candidate I think he's a big squish I
think ultimately if I'm
going to the ballot in on November 8th I
guess I vote for Oz because he does have
this one lucky break in that the man
he's running against is absolutely
Dreadful he's fanatically in favor of
the most radical policies in the country
he said John fetterman said if he had a
magic wand the first thing that he would
do wouldn't be to cure childhood illness
or you know solve world hunger no it
would be to let murderers out of prison
so he's just so awful
Oz seems kind of like a Romney type
which is awful but I guess there's a
better chance he caucuses with the
Republicans than than that John
fetterman would
so if I'm looking at it today and I I
guess this is what a lot of Pennsylvania
moderates and some conservatives are
thinking too they're saying well I gotta
vote for Oz the other option is just so
bad Oz is at least a somewhat reasonable
guy according to a poll of a little over
a thousand voters by the market research
firm WIC Oz is leading fetterman by four
and a half points that is outside the
margin of error so that's good a lot
other polls have the race basically in a
dead heat but when you think about all
of the attacks on the Republicans and
you think about all of the media
propping up John fetterman this is
really good news really good news
except for this
the pennsylvanians have been voting
since early November or early September
rather I'm sorry
since early September the pennsylvanians
have been voting for almost two months
great the pl it's breaking at the end
we're now looking forward to a debate
finally between Dr Oz and John fetterman
fetterman had been running away from a
debate because he act he actually can
can barely form a coherent English
sentence right now both because he has
health problems and because he's not the
brightest bulb in the pack and never has
been so he's just been running away
doesn't want to do any of the debates
finally he agrees to do one
but who cares what does it matter if
election day is no longer election day
if it's now election not election week
not even election month it's what is it
election two months now or more
if the the debates happen a week or two
before the the election it doesn't
matter at all if the polls start to
break for Dr Oz a week or two before the
election it doesn't matter at all how
many votes have already been cast
that's the question that you've got to
answer right now you're seeing the same
issue in in Ohio
great news JD Vance is up over Tim Ryan
in Ohio and JD Vance the Republican
candidate is up over Tim Ryan the
Democrat specifically because of the
debates because JD Vance destroyed Tim
Ryan with facts and logic like any good
YouTube conservative and crushed him in
the debates and so you're seeing that
reflected in the polls there's a poll
now that has Vance up by 4.1 percent
over Ryan that's a signal poll that is
again beyond the poll's margin of error
which is 2.58 percent this poll was
conducted October 14th through the 18th
of 1500 likely voters this is a very
important poll these numbers should
really really matter except
Ohio also has early voting and both of
these states have mass vote by mail so
vote by mail makes fraud much easier to
to commit and it makes it much more
likely to happen
and then even if the people who are
receiving the ballots by mail just
completely follow the rules and there's
no Shenanigans and there's no ballot
Harvesters and there's no corpses voting
in the election doesn't matter if if
they cast their votes before the the
debates take place before the polls
break for JD Vance it's just not going
to matter so it's just you're you're
still seeing this year in real time the
way that the Democrats rig the election
don't let them tell you that there's no
rigging that this is the most wonderful
protected serious dignified election in
all of human history and if you question
it you're a terrible insurrectionist
fascist don't let them tell you that
they are rigging it you are watching it
being rigged in real time so how could
how could John fetterman win in
Pennsylvania how could Tim Ryan win in
Ohio very easily they don't even need to
mess with the voting machines or cheat
about the count in the days and weeks
that for whatever reason it now takes us
to count ballots they can just change
the way that you vote in the first place
and in some cases it's going to be
contrary to the state constitution like
the mail-in ballots in Pennsylvania but
in some cases it will be perfectly legal
and it will just give Democrats an
advantage but you can see that the
momentum right now for the Republicans
among the actual people is tremendous
you can you see it in New York right now
the the Republican gubernatorial
candidate in New York is leading the
Democrat Governor in True Blue New York
a poll of 1056 likely voters this is
conducted by coefficient October 18th to
19th shows Lee zeldin the Republican not
just in a dead heat or closing the space
or he he's within Striking Distance he's
leading Kathy hokel the Democrat
Governor in in New York
now it's a it's a small margin but he's
leading her 50 55.6 I'm sorry 45.6 to
45.3 and you've got another 9.1 percent
of Voters who are undecided so yeah it's
within the margin of error but he's
actually got the slight edge here even
though it's in a dead heat and then
you've got another nine percent plus of
Voters who are undecided how are the
undecideds breaking right now poll after
polls show that the undecideds are
breaking for the Republicans this is
really great news right how is zeldin
doing that zeldon is doing that he's
he's winning among white voters 48 to
44. he's winning Hispanic voters by a
pretty significant margin he's winning
so those Hispanic voters goodness
gracious it's 18 is the margin that he's
winning by he's winning in the other
races too and this is crucial
uh zeldin is not winning the black vote
the black vote is very firmly uh in the
Democrat camp
but he's pulling 18 18 of the black vote
Republicans traditionally get anywhere
from I don't know maybe 12 down to eight
percent of the black vote so you you
don't when people talk about brexit for
instance or when they talk about you
know pulling uh black voters away from
the Democrats who have been mistreating
them for so long you don't need to to
get
55 of the black vote you don't need to
get 35 of the black vote you just need
to get like 15 of the black vote and the
Democrats are toast so this is great
great news and it's good news for zeldon
too because the Democrats cannot with
any plausibility
use their favorite attack which is to
call Republicans racist and terrible and
say that anytime they win an election
it's because of white supremacy you see
here the deciding factor in these races
is not race
and it's not sex
and it's not
any of the not it's not religion even
exactly
do you know what it is
it's class
the Republicans
are very firmly the party of the working
class and the middle class true
the the Democrats are the party of weird
Elite people who believe in transiting
the kids and who watch all those stupid
TV shows that no one else really watches
and go to see the big Hollywood movies
that nobody actually goes to see anymore
that the Democrats have become the party
of a a an elite sort of cultural bubble
that is exerting less and less influence
on the broader culture previously the
big institutions Hollywood Harvard and
Yale all of the the prestigious Elite
institutions in the country used to
exert a ton of influence over the common
sense in the popular culture that is not
really the case anymore and so you're
seeing Time After Time the Republicans
who used to be portrayed as Rich Uncle
Penny bags you know they're the party of
the Monopoly man or something the
Democrats they're the part of the
working class that's completely over
okay and the only Republicans who are
not getting it or the Republicans who
still think we're running in 2003 or
2004 or something but the political
landscape has has completely shifted
very much to the benefit of the GOP this
is good we got to win back the culture
that's why we got to do it at The Ballot
Box we got to do it on our screens and
we got to do it in our coffee cup that's
why you got to check out Black Rifle
coffee right now head on over to
blackriflecoffee.com use promo code at
Knowles here at the daily wire we are
committed to winning back the culture
losing is not an option losing is for
losers okay there's too much riding on
agriculture and part of that means
supporting businesses where the values
align with our own which is why I'm very
excited to tell you that we've teamed up
with Black Rifle Coffee Company many of
you know about Black Rifle already it's
a veteran founded and operated coffee
company that has made it their mission
to hire 10 000 veterans they're well on
their way one of the many laudable
things Black Rifle does is help service
members successfully transition from the
military into entrepreneurship and
they're constantly giving back to
veteran foundations as well as law
enforcement and First Responders by
purchasing from Black Rifle Coffee
Company you are directly supporting the
military service Community what about
the coffee itself it's bold it's strong
it's really really good Black Rifle is
very selective about where they Source
their coffee beans from and disciplined
when it comes to ensuring the freshness
of every single bag we keep it stocked
here at the office everyone loves it go
to Black riflecoffee.com use promo code
nulls for 10 off your first order and
when you sign up for a new coffee Club
subscription the subscription gives you
free shipping on all coffee Club orders
Early Access to Club deals and
promotions and special discounts from
their partner Brands that's black
riflecoffee.com promo code Knowles for
10 off your first order or when you sign
up to become a coffee Club member Black
Rifle coffee supporting veterans and
America's coffee
the class divide politically right now
is nowhere clearer than in the UK I just
got to spend the last week in the UK
because I was over there uh for the
baptism of Candace Candace Owens and her
husband George's daughter I assume they
picked me not only because I'm Catholic
you know for this baptism but probably
even more so because I'm Italian and a
Godfather really should be Italian and
have a nice little bow tie you know and
kind of shut his his chin out underneath
and Grant favors uh to his various
Associates on the day of his daughter's
wedding so it was a real pleasure to be
over there and the the fights that we
see here the culture war fights in the
U.S are really really clear over there
and that class divide is really really
clear over there one of the big fights
that is back again now is the fight over
the brexit
Britain was part of the EU and then
Britain wanted to leave the EU and there
was a huge divide in Britain over this
and here was the Divide
regular normal working class and middle
class people wanted to leave the EU
because it was a complete disaster and
it was destroying the British culture
but the sort of wealthy Cosmopolitan
fancy laptop set that feels no
allegiance to Nation or church or family
or anything like that they wanted to
stay in the EU and their arguments were
pretty much just economic they said well
we'll have more money if we're in the EU
possibly and they were for the open
borders it was for all the kind of
leftist utopian nonsense that the libs
are pushing here in the U.S and all
around the world and it was the normal
people who said no I don't want to just
completely destroy my culture and open
up all of my borders and lose all of my
traditions and break down my whole way
of life I don't want to do that I like
my way of life I want to conserve
something I saw this I had a great
privilege of meeting a ton of listeners
to the show in the UK I didn't realize
we had that kind of an international
audience but at a nice opportunity for
people to come up on the street and I
would chat with with everybody
and I'll tell you
it was not the Provost of the very fancy
Social Club who came up to me on the
street okay it wasn't the very elite
wonderful Tweety people walking up to me
on the street as a general rule it was
working class and middle class people
there's a lot of people in the service
industry it was a lot of
just like normal guys and that is going
to be the political divide here in the
UK and in the U.S because you've you've
now got a left in this country a left
that is part of the ruling class that is
defined by the most insane political
positions and the the most the clearest
of all in its insanity is this desire to
transgender little kids and so it
doesn't take a PhD in political
philosophy for someone to look at that
and say man that is completely nuts I
don't want that doesn't take a PhD in
political philosophy to say hey how
about you don't flood my country with
millions of foreign Nationals who have
absolutely no connection to our
traditional culture whatsoever
it doesn't take a PhD in political
philosophy to say hey maybe we shouldn't
kill all the kids kill all the little
babies and and actually the old people
too now because they're pushing for
quote unquote euthanasia assisted
suicide
it doesn't it doesn't take a PhD in
political philosophy to say hey should
we really be hurtling toward World War
III over a territorial dispute in
Ukraine that all of the elite
institutions seem to be really really
focused on but Ordinary People we kind
of just want to heat our homes and
actually that's a related problem this
energy crisis that's being caused by
this ever greater escalation of a war in
Ukraine it doesn't take really really
fancy people to fancy institutions to
know that
Ordinary People on the street working
normal jobs having normal families
having normal lives they are much much
more sophisticated on these questions
than our so-called Elite I think this
played a huge role in why the UK
government fell last week so I'm not
saying I had I had anything to do with
it necessarily all right but here's what
I'm saying I land in the UK immediately
the Prime Minister resigns
she knew there was a new boss in town
put my little bow tie on do my Churchill
impression walking over to 10 Downing
Liz truss
who had just been elected she probably
hadn't even finished moving in to 10
Downing Street yet
she resigned after just 45 days in
office that is just slightly over four
scaramucci's okay that is a very very
short period of time
now she was a Tory but she still is a
toy she's not dead you know she she is
nominally a conservative but the problem
is the British Tories the British
conservatives are not actually
conservative
they don't conserve anything
this isn't to be some cheap shot at the
Tories and saying they should move a
little further right they don't they
actually don't believe in conserving
basically anything the vast majority of
them and Liz truss in particular came in
as a kind of weak establishment pick
that wasn't interested in actually
conserving any part of the traditional
culture so you have to ask yourself just
looking internationally right now why is
this why was this government different
all the momentum is on the right all the
momentum is for the conservatives right
now starting really with Donald Trump
that really is what escalated it this
very popular very old school kind of
conservative not you know the Egghead
technocratic kind of right wing that we
saw for the last 20 years but a real old
school kind of know we're going to
conserve our country because you know
God family country borders make America
great again that kind of stuff
you get it with Trump you get it in
Italy with Georgia Maloney you get it in
Ukraine with Victor Orban you just had
elections in Sweden that went much more
right-wing you're seeing this bubble
Bubble Up throughout the West so why is
it that the UK when they elect a
conservative government it falls within
45 days
because the kind of conservative that
got elected in the UK is the same
squishy weak losing kind of conservative
just maybe cut my taxes a little bit but
actually we'll probably just end up
raising taxes a little later on that
kind of you know just let me keep my
money but we're not going to affect any
kind of culture or social social change
that kind of conservative doesn't play
anymore
I don't think that kind of conservative
ever really played
okay that that's the kind of
conservative
that the libs always wanted us to be the
libs they like the Romney kind of
conservative
the libs they like the kind of moderate
center-right kind of conservative the
libs even like the kind of caricature of
Libertarians this is why when
conservatives are portrayed in left-wing
media and I mean the entertainment media
here they're always this kind of
libertarian type who never takes a
strong stand really on the social issues
and I'm thinking of Ron Swanson on Parks
and Rec you know just kind of a lot let
me do whatever I want you do whatever
you want that's all we're going to do
and we're not gonna you know I'm not
gonna push my views on you and you're
not going to push your views on me
we're just gonna I don't know we're
gonna cut taxes we're all gonna have a
little bit more money but we're not
going to say anything about the culture
or the country you're conserving
anything
that's the kind of conservative that the
Liberals want
because that kind of conservative
doesn't pose any real challenge
Mitt Romney they fought against them
they beat him in the election in 2012
But Mitt Romney never threatened the
left's agenda ever
Donald Trump did
that's why they're that's why they're
still trying to arrest the guy okay
that's why they're doing everything they
can in 2020 they did everything they
could to prevent people from electing
him again and in 2024 they're doing
everything they can to keep him off of
the ballot
the kind of conservative the left fears
is the Trump kind the Georgia Maloney
kind the Victor or Bond kind look at the
UK the Nigel farage kind the brexit kind
the the sort of no we're not going to
accept your stupid status quo albeit
with slightly lower taxes no we're going
to upend the status quo and we're going
to upend this this absolutely desiccated
decadent status quo of the liberal
establishment to return to what made our
countries great and it's it's basic
stuff
it's at least simple enough to
understand it's it's God it's family
it's your Traditions it's your culture
it's your community that's what it is
okay and so let's trust didn't get in so
she's the lone conservative who gets
booted out on the western stage okay I
hope that the Brits have enough sense to
to run a real conservative for that
position next time they probably
probably won't though the libs want us
to present ourselves as that just kind
of disconnected party of cutting taxes
and Eggheads looking at spreadsheets
that's what Joe Biden is still talking
about that Joe Biden is still talking
about politics as though it's 20 years
ago which is no surprise he probably
thinks it is 20 years ago he's still
referring to Republicans as the party of
the Monopoly man
we're not going to stop there
they're going to do big Farmer's bidding
to repeal my plan to allow Medicare to
negotiate prescription drugs prices we
pay the highest of the world and doing
so it's going to raise drug prices
and they're going to raise big farmers
profits they're doing fine big Pharma
they're not hurting at all
and they're going to raise your health
insurance premiums
it's mega mega
trickle down
mega mega trickle down the kind of
policies that have failed the country
before and will fail it again
and will mean more wealth to the very
wealthy
higher inflation for the middle class
that's the choice we're facing that's
why I think that we're going to do just
fine thank you mega mega trickled down
that the Republicans are Shilling for
big Pharma are you
are you making that argument with a
straight face
the Democrats who just spent the last
three years shutting down our country
and taking away all of our rights and
our way of life to force us to buy a
product from Big Pharma
and the Republicans whenever the
Republicans say hey actually I don't
really trust Pfizer I don't actually
trust moderna those Republicans they are
de-platformed they're kicked out of
school they're fired from their jobs
they're prevented from interacting in
society
you're telling me that we're the
We're the Party of big Pharma what
planet are you on Joe Biden it's exactly
the opposite
the mega MaGa trickled on the
Republicans are running on tariffs now
okay the Republicans are running on
waging trade Wars with China okay is
there Democrats who are who are running
on just to Outsource everything all that
matters is taking up GDP a little bit
it's the Democrats pushing that stuff
Joe Biden's biggest contribution to U.S
politics right now I mean this sincerely
is because he is ancient he shows you
how times have changed because he's
ancient and he's not as quick as he used
to be and he's he's not really familiar
with the current state of the political
debates he's using the talking points
from 15 years ago 20 years ago when
Republicans were acting like big losers
when Republicans even when they won
elections would just lose on everything
and failed to conserve even the women's
bathroom fail to conserve the definition
of marriage fail to conserve our borders
fail to conserve American industry fail
to conserve everything they were just
complete losers the more they won the
worse it got it seemed for conservatism
isn't that amazing
in so many ways and then the Republicans
reverted back to the older kind of view
of things the the conservatism that
predated the year 2000 or the late 1990s
okay they went back to make America
great again that was the slogan and Joe
Biden hasn't caught up with that but if
you're if you're you're a regular old
voter looking at the situation right now
and Joe Biden is telling you those
Republicans they're just Shilling for
big Pharma they're the they're the party
of the plutocrats they're the party of
the elite do you believe that for one
second
no it's it's just so offensive because
it's so manifestly not true
in reality in reality the Republicans
the conservatives broadly in the west
are not the party of the Monopoly man
we are not the party of mega mega
trickle down whatever that means we're
not we're not even the party of put the
economy first we obviously we all want a
flourishing economy we want to grow jobs
we want we want prosperity
but that is a means to an end okay we
don't want to make an idol out of that
we don't want to worship Mammon things
go very bad when you do that we want a
flourishing economy for the purpose of a
flourishing society and in a society
where we're castrating poor little kids
and pumping them full of cross-sex
hormones and killing a ton of babies and
getting rid of all of our borders and
Outsourcing all of the American industry
and do it that is not a flourishing
society and even if even if GDP ticks up
a little bit and I'm not convinced that
it will that is not that is not a
justification for it that would be
putting the cart before the horse in
reality what the conservatives are right
now is the party of Common Sense the
libs they have all their studies which
are usually nonsense they've got all
their white lab coats and they've got
all their fancy people and they've got
control over all the prestigious
institutions and they're going to tell
us with a totally straight face oh no
that you know that covid shot that's 100
effective at stopping the you the
transmission of the virus and it's
stopping the uh the infection and oh
yeah actually little boys little boys
know that they're little girls from the
womb actually from the time they're in
the womb even though when they're in the
womb they're not human beings at all
they're just clumps of cells and those
things are obviously completely
contradictory but you've got listen
we're really smart we've got studies you
want me to show you my studies that's
the libs okay and the conservatives
right now are the party that says yeah
I actually don't think my son is my
daughter
call me crazy you know I think maybe we
shouldn't have those millions of illegal
aliens pouring into our country I don't
yeah I know I don't look I don't maybe I
don't even have a really reasoned out
eloquent argument I just think that's
not a good idea you know maybe we
shouldn't have
drag queen Story Hour in kindergarten
you know
that's called common sense
and so while I was in the UK this was
was this coincidence I'm not sure if
this was coincidence I get attacked by
one of the lean leading limeys
who is now always poking his nose into
American politics that of course would
be John Oliver John Oliver went after me
personally on the issue of transiting
the kids
I've been fueled by a lack of basic
knowledge about what gender affirming
care actually consists of summed up by
comments like this if a child walked
into a doctor's office and said doc I
want you to cut my fingers off the doc
would say you've got some problems kid
we need to refer you to a psychiatrist
if the same child walks into that
doctor's office and says doc I want you
to cut my uterus out the doctor would
say that doctor would say oh well you're
a wonderful Brave person you're so right
we do need to cut your uterus out as
soon as possible let's get this young
lady over to the operating room well
what are you talking about absolutely
every bit of that is unrealistic from
the fact that no one in this country has
ever been able to have one conversation
with a doctor without first discussing
Insurance to the notion of a young child
using the term doc why is the fictional
child in this [ __ ] scenario using
the same vocabulary as a chaotic rabbit
from the 1940s none of this makes any
sense none of this makes any sense there
isn't it ha ha ha so his answer to my
objection to the the doctors tranzing
the kids his objection or his reaction
to that is to make a joke about how we
should have socialist Health Care
and to make a joke about Bugs Bunny
and frankly
those are the strongest arguments he had
against what I said
now he he went on and tried to muster
something resembling a coherent argument
so what's my position my position is
that Health Care institutions at the
encouragement of the culture and the
state by the way going all the way up to
Joe Biden all the way up to the federal
government are encouraging little kids
to undergo gender transition which
involves bodily mutilations it involves
the injection of chemicals popping of
pills to castrate themselves often to
sterilize themselves to make them look
more like the opposite sex that's my
argument I'm saying that's bad and John
Oliver said what that's not really
happening to hear some tell it as soon
as a child declares themselves trans
there is an immediate irreversible
surgical decision undertaken and there
just isn't so let's break down exactly
what gender affirming care consists of
because in younger children it can mean
nothing more than a social transition
like calling them by a new name or
giving them a new haircut or clothing or
or providing them with psychological or
behavioral support because to be very
clear prepubescent children are not
eligible for medical interventions now
at the onset of puberty an adolescent
and their family might consider puberty
blockers hormones that delay puberty
there we go but oh you just kind of
there you just kind of undermined his
whole argument
because he said now this is not
happening this is not happening
my British accent has not improved while
I've been in the UK so I'll just go back
to do my I'll I'll go back to every
British accent just being Paul McCartney
John Oliver says you know this isn't
happening actually you know this isn't
happening it's not no no children are
being trans or anything okay no uh no
prepubescent children are going on
puberty blockers until they hit puberty
then they go on the puberty bloggers
yeah talk to John and George and Ringo
about that
obviously
children who are not about to hit
puberty don't need to go on the puberty
blockers in order to block puberty
because they're not going through
puberty
but little children
who are
about to begin puberty are being put on
these puberty blockers and it's not just
a fringe case and it's not just one
weird story here or there this is being
pushed to Nationwide and it's being
pushed by the federal government and
it's being pushed by the very confused
mentally ill man Dr Richard Levine who
thinks that he's a woman and who is
pushing his own sexual Hang-Ups on poor
little kids and he's encouraging them to
take puberty blockers and to take
cross-sex hormones and to have gender
mutilation surgeries all of which fall
under the umbrella of gender affirming
care according to these absolute Ghouls
and these child abusers and these
perverts that is all happening and John
Oliver is making the argument as the
left always does this isn't happening
and it's good that it is
that's why this isn't happening and it's
really really good we're not rigging the
election and it's so good that we rigged
the election
if you say we rigged the election you're
an insurrectionist terrorist here's a 3
000 word Time magazine article telling
you how we rate the election
we're not transiting the kit we nobody
is pushing for abortion on demand for
that apology and it's good that we have
the right to abortion up until the very
moment of birth
nobody's transiting the kids and kids
need this gender affirming care well
this doesn't affect little This only
affects older kids but we have to put
them on puberty blockers 25 year olds
don't go through puberty guys
and they claim the libs claim that these
drugs are reversible they're totally
reversible they're simply not you know
go watch Matt's movie the one thing I
missed when I was out of the country
that I really wanted to attend I was
supposed to speak at Matt's rally to
stop transiting the kids it was a huge
success I was looking at the the photos
and the videos a huge huge success why
because the people are obviously on our
side of this issue the reason I bring up
John Oliver is
is not even to you know just kind of get
into a urinating contest with this limey
who's got a nose for American politics
the reason I bring it up is
if you heard my argument which is hey
it's kind of bad that children are
allowed to go to doctor and encourage to
go to doctors right now and mutilate
their bodies and then you heard his
argument which is that's come on that's
not real what does he sound like Bugs
Bunny hot come on no they're just
getting gender affirming care and
they're being told that they're actually
the boys are little girls and then
they're being put on puberty bloggers
come on man if you just heard those two
arguments which one do you think is the
normal argument which which guy there do
you think is the crazy radical guy and
which guy do you think is the normal
Common Sense guy I don't mean to toot my
own horn but I think any unless you are
a radical leftist
even if you don't like me personally
even if you don't care about the
transgender issue you hear those two
arguments the argument that we are
making is obviously the common sense
normal argument that everyone has
believed throughout all of human history
until five minutes ago
and the radical crazy Fringe argument is
the John Oliver argument it's not even
much of an argument at all
and even you know even to John Oliver's
point when he says and they're not all
going on drugs some of them are just
being told that they're actually the
opposite sex as if that doesn't matter
as if the physical world is all that
matters and all that matters is putting
chemicals into your body no of course
not
if a little of a little kid a little boy
is told every day starting in
kindergarten that he's actually a little
girl and there is a a kind of social
currency that goes along with
identifying as transgender and it's
being pushed by the president of the
United States
don't you think that's either going to
deepen his sexual confusion if he has
some already or it's just going to plant
it there in the first place don't you
think that the social metaphysical
aspect of Our Lives matters too I think
it does in many ways I think it matters
a lot more than the physical aspect of
Our Lives of course that that's child
abuse too and it's so amazing it's so
incredible that the libs on the one hand
are are so belligerently opposed to
so-called homosexual conversion therapy
you know where a gay guy shows up to a
psychiatrist and says or psychologist
and says hey Doc I have the same sex
attraction and I don't really want to
and I don't want to live a homosexual
lifestyle so but I don't know what to do
about it and then the doctor says well
here are some tools you know to kind of
try to deal with those desires that you
don't want to have
that is that's the worst thing ever that
has to be banned to people who the
doctors who practice that need to be
thrown in prison that's gay conversion
there that's so awful
but the libs are actively encouraging
transgender conversion therapy on the
other side two little kids the kind of
conversion therapy that says little kid
goes up and says you know you know uh
doc I actually think I'm a girl this
week and then this Predator doctor says
oh yeah you are you are a girl stop
don't even call yourself Johnny anymore
you're Sally and all your teachers are
going to have to call you Sally and
pretty soon we're going to get you on
those puberty blockers that by the way
are going to make a ton of money for big
Pharma and yeah then we're going to get
you into the gender mutilation surgeries
and oh yeah that
that is
both of those Therapies
are operating on the idea that talking
things out and forming one's psychology
and spiritual views on this matter of
your metaphysical self of your soul is
going to affect your life and your
identity
and John Oliver is saying oh no it's not
a big deal when it's being done
pro-trans it's the worst thing in the
world when it's the gay conversion
therapy and it's it's it's threatening
people's lives and it's going to cause
them all to commit suicide but oh when
it's with the little kids that you're
convincing them they're the opposite sex
oh it doesn't even matter it's nothing
that's nothing it's no big deal
and by the way it's not happening and
it's good that it is it keeps getting
more and more
extreme and clear by the way there's a
there's a new poll out I've said it on
the show a number of times that I am
very confident the vast majority of
Americans oppose translating the kids I
said if you do a poll on it I promise
you it's going to be overwhelmingly
people oppose training the kids well now
we have the poll there's a poll
conducted uh in partnership with the
Trafalgar group
uh this was conducted by Convention of
States action and the football found
that 80 percent of American voters
believe minors should be required to
wait until they are adults to pursue
transgender procedures now I think these
butcher procedures should be outlawed
period I think they help nobody they
harm a lot of people they're deeply
disordered and they violate the
Hippocratic Oath for adults as well as
for kids but at the very least you have
your eighty percent four four out of
five Americans believe that we should
not trans the kids
which raises a big question
not about translating the kids but about
our democracy
how is it that the most powerful
politicians and institutions in America
keep pushing this stuff when 80 of the
voters oppose it
if we have our sacred democracy and the
answer is obviously because the the
powers that be are not actually
accountable to the people and it's not
just on translating the kids it's not
immigration
Harvard Harris poll that I cite
frequently says
vast majority of Americans want to
drastically reduce all immigration in
America not just illegal immigration but
legal immigration too and yet why is it
that no matter who gets elected we get
more and more immigration Democrats
actively pushing at Republicans allowing
it to happen
how can that be if we have a Democratic
Republic well it it can only be if the
powers that be are not actually
accountable to the people the
corporations pushing this nonsense are
not accountable in the uh even to the
market forces and the politicians are
not accountable to their voters but that
first part is important too because we
often hear well and this is from the
more libertarian style conservatives
they'll say yeah that government it is
corrupt you're right there those
politicians they're not actually that
accountable to the voters and that's why
we need to defend the free market and we
need to defend the corporations to work
out in the marketplace uh exactly how
the Americans want to live but that's
not actually how it works one there is
no such thing as a perfectly organic
free Marketplace that there is always a
political Authority that sets the rules
of any Marketplace a physical
Marketplace or this kind of metaphorical
Marketplace but furthermore we know 80
percent of Americans hate this stuff all
the big corporations are pushing it
so how can that be the only way that can
be the case is if even the corporations
are not actually accountable to their
customers to the supposed free market if
if what we have is really more like a
rigged game you know we launched
speaking of the free Marketplace we
launched Jeremy's razors just a few
months ago
we've already taken millions of dollars
away from woke razor companies the exact
kind of companies that I am talking
about right now that hate your guts and
that use that money to better we've
taken that money and now we use it to
better support the stuff you believe in
now the time has come for Jeremy's
razors to look Inward and conduct a
totally legit not at all Hollow or
contrived Dei audit of ourselves so here
it is
is Jeremy's razors diverse
no the razors are great we don't need to
make different ones our Jeremy's razors
Equitable uh Yes actually when you buy a
Founder's kit Equity is transferred away
from your pocket and into Jeremy's
pockets and lastly our Jeremy's razors
inclusive well of course they are they
include blades so there you have it
Jeremy's razors is now Dei self
accredited and still the only Razer
brand that actually upholds virtue
instead of merely signaling a false
version of it if you have not already
done so get your shave kit at
jeremy'srazors.com this weekend also Ben
Shapiro released a brand new episode of
his Sunday special it features a very
special guest president of Brazil jair
bolsonaro you can watch the episode on
daily wire Plus or listen on Apple
podcast Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts
the push for these radical unpopular
usually weird kind of sex policies from
the top from the established Elite
keeps getting more and more extreme the
latest video from old Nick's Pub which
is the Eugene Oregon venue hosting a
child drag show featuring a performance
by an 11 year old child and free
admission free admission for kids 10 and
under used to be there was ladies night
at the bar and ladies would get in for
free and they'd get cheap drinks because
then the men could hit on the women well
now our cultures moved past that now we
have kids 10 and under night at the bar
and presumably that's for exactly the
same reason this is the bar that we're
talking about
women Invaders and demonic forces waged
across the land upon a Mountaintop the
powers of the Ethereal Overlord and the
Demonic savior Goliath on holy views of
light were met with a laser glass and
demonic Flames were met with ethereal
blades
as defeat befell them the leader from
their Skies kneeled to submission and
was impregnated righteously
infected with the Sea Of The Dark One
the Fallen leader Lee decimated and
besieged inside of black and blue there
a parasitic fetus throbbed and bribed
all right I think I've seen 74 by the
Insidious so you see in this I mean you
can hear the the narration going on all
this demonic satanic talk this kind of
weird occult alternate history of the
world and then the imagery on stage is
just a dude dressed up like a demon with
devil horns uh doing all sorts of things
with people and kind of all sorts of
satanic imagery the pentagram and all
the rest of it now they're going to be
some people out there who are a little
less culturally minded who are not you
know maybe they're not all that
religious and and they're going to say
oh you know look is this weird yes is it
wrong to let kids into a drag bar yeah
that for sure isn't but when we're
talking about the imagery Michael come
on isn't it are we really going to have
another satanic Panic here I mean does
it does this really matter yeah it's
dumb it's weird but is it really evil is
it really so bad do we care I mean it's
all just kind of Make-Believe and
pretend and just silly and random isn't
it there are a lot of people who hold
that view
and my question then always is
if it's if it's all just so silly and
random if it's all meaningless if these
symbols don't have any meaning
why is it always the same symbols that
we're seeing why is it that the deputy
monkey pox coordinator for Joe Biden
wears the very same symbol that you saw
in that satanic image
why he always wears the the pentagram
and he has a not only a pentagram
leather harness on that he photographs
himself wearing he also has a pentagram
tattoo on his pectoral muscle
why is it that Biden's
energy advisor nuclear energy advisor
Sam Brinton dresses up in all these same
kinds of weird leather
occult demonic sort of things why is it
that when you see the pro-abortion rally
and the transient the kids rally and all
the crazy colorfully haired uh radicals
who are hoisting The Pride progress flag
and they always look the same and
they've got the same kinds of why is
that and why does it always seem to come
back to the devil why is it that Saul
Alinsky when he wrote Rules for Radicals
the most important book for leftist
organizing in America probably in a
hundred years why is it that in the
acknowledgments he mentions Lucifer and
he says you know I've got to mention
I've got to acknowledge here the devil
who lost himself heaven but won himself
a kingdom
why is that
why
why do the same images which are the
images that have cropped up the same
symbols that have cropped up for all of
human history why are those the ones
being used
and I think the obvious answer is
because symbols represent something
the symbols represent a symbolized so
yes they dress up in their stupid
outfits and with the horns and they've
got this the stupid pentagram on the
wall but why are they doing that because
the that physical representation is
pointing to a metaphysical reality
that is evil it's just evil it's bad and
we can't we can't just throw our hands
up and write it off and say well you
know look
some people like images of angels and
cherubim and God and and some people
like images and symbols of the devil and
the pentagrams and the transit and it
just it's so it just so happens that the
people who go to church on Sunday and do
their jobs and get married and have kids
and take care of their family and I want
a good country and vote almost always
for the conservatives and don't want to
destroy our entire Society those guys
always just really like the kind of nice
Angelic imagery and the people who want
to kill the babies and trans the kids
and open the borders and destroy our
country they for whatever just
coincidence So Random such a coincidence
they're always the ones with the satanic
imagery
I think it's a little more than
coincidence I think that really when you
get down to it politics is not about
some weird cockamamie five-point
ideology that was cooked up in 1752 and
now that's all politics means forever
and ever no I think
politics is about do you want to do good
stuff
or bad stuff do you want to promote
truth or do you want to promote
falsehood do you want your society and
your country to be beautiful or do you
want it to be ugly like that drag bar
that's now luring children in so that
creepy men can prey on them what do you
want what do you want we have
political rights okay and for a long
time the conservatives we we just kind
of talked ourselves into this insane
idea that actually you know we don't
have any right to stop this stuff you
know if Google if Google wants to rig
the election well by golly we just have
to build our own Google but we have no
right to stop them from censoring us and
promoting all this terrible stuff and
suppressing all this because we we do we
have rights that's what political
freedom is that's true in the whole
anglo-american tradition goes back much
further than that too
that's the idea that Edmund Burke talked
about this
the Great
the great conservative philosopher
he said you know
there is there is an exalted Freedom
Beyond just titillating yourself
Beyond just asserting your individual
appetites and desires there's a more
exalted Freedom that that finds that
that Liberty even in servitude itself at
times when we are recognizing that we
are in a community we have obligations
to one another and we don't want to live
in a country that's transiting all the
kids okay that is what conservatives are
waking up to in America that's what the
Trump movement was about that's why
Trump he didn't run on the slogan make
taxes low again
make killing babies and chopping off
genitals a private decision again okay
he didn't run on that on that week week
kind of pseudo right-wing
pseudo-conservatism that has been dead
since the early 2000s and that Britain
just learned because they tried to push
it again with Liz trust that's that's
not going anywhere okay either either
our society is not going to remain
neutral it's not going to have stasis
we're either going to move toward a good
country we're either going to make our
country great again and our civilization
great again
or we're going to go to that bar with
all those kids and all the demons in
Eugene Oregon the choice I I think Still
Remains ours it's an uphill battle
because of the disconnect between the
established powers and the actual desire
of the people but the polls show it we
can rest assured the people are broadly
on our side it is simply up to us to
assert our political rights now you know
it's music Monday I'm so very glad to be
here for music Monday the producers have
chosen
assault I don't know anything about this
song or this musician but I'm going to
give you my absolute
highest most sophisticated pop cultural
analysis you know I wonder Mike and I've
come to say hello I'm I'm a rap Mogul A
hip-hop Maven I'm just a culture vulture
baby the rest of the show is continuing
now you don't want to miss it if you're
not a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
foreign